chris brockman mike deltufo good hour
three to you tj jefferson still trying
to take in what his head coach of the
dallas cowboys mike mccarthy said in
hour number two and i'm gonna stop
talking about our in studio guest as if
he's not here because he's staring at me
saying when are you gonna introduce me
i feel like i feel i could feel it i
could feel it from my right good to see
my hall of fame i love it what did mike
mccarthy say
no he came on the program and um you
know it was nice enough to uh to to come
on and he said he did talk to jerry
jones about the stuff that jerry's
saying in um in
in you know in public you know and and
and interesting enough on you know how
is the head coach supposed to say take
you know um uh the con did you hear the
stuff he was saying about dan quinn the
the jerry jones stuff okay so when dan
quinn stayed okay
he said all of us wanted dan to stay
that was the key to our continuity here
and then he and then he mentioned how
quinn joins sean payton and jason
garrett in in coaches who want to stay
because they love to be the head coach
of the dallas cowboys everyone
so my point is quote in my mind a lot of
logic as to why they might not take a
job right now rather than one or
or wait and see how the cards go in the
future
when asked what that meant about you
know his current coach
jones said mike mccarthy knows that
someday somebody other than him will be
coach of the cowboys
that's jerry right right
you don't expect that did you ever have
somebody at the top of the flow chart
talk about a coach like that no that
never happened right no we had a real
good argument well it was al you know
when i pulled out the overhead god bless
his soul the great outdated it was old
you know it was all when the overhead
come out right other than now everything
else but no but that didn't happen when
dungey was there right i mean they
switched up to gruden right i mean like
that well that wasn't pretty either
right that wasn't pretty either
losing your head coach especially one i
don't know how long mike mccarthy is
with all the timeouts and the decision
making and the craziness that went on
all year long i mean you you saw it lead
up to what the cowboys ended and
you you can't
predict jerry jones's demise right then
it plays out in front of him and he does
nothing about it i mean you know he's
gonna shake the tree i'm just wondering
how that plays in the locker room that's
on him when jerry is your owner you
don't worry about like when i was i only
didn't worry about it i mean
you won't ask to go see him he'll give
you the answer what you're looking for
did you ever go to al's office al davis
yeah i went to al in the locker room to
get the defense changed over to 4-3 and
rob ryan wanted to kill me sorry rubble
and i got derek burgess outside who's
the meanest left hand in the game and
the baddest one i ever played with
and then i want to rush and then i'm
teaching tommy kelly how to play the
game and they just gave him a 50 million
contract and then i got chris clemons
the young guy that turned out to be
pretty good in seattle remember him
right yes and i had him young so i had a
good full group and robbo's playing with
this 3-4 stretch thing and we're in
denver they got ben hamilton in that
other little guard and they're pulling
me out on third down i'm going crazy i
want to pull my air out so after the
game derek gibson looks at me though
florida state someone will say what's
the matter with you i mean i rich i got
smoke coming out of my ears right i was
pulled out on third down all game long
he was like go to al i'm like what you
know i'm i'm used to tampa you know i
don't see dungeon go see money you know
go see go talk to ron i don't go see the
head the owner of the team
go see al you want something change
around here so i walk around the corner
i'm stealing my cleats i hadn't done any
work i'd walk around the corner he's
standing at the locker room
i walked up to him i said what'd you
bring me there to do he said excuse me
i said what did you bring me here today
it's your opener with al davis
listen i had smoke coming out of my ears
at this point rich they could have sent
me home and i wouldn't have gave a damn
at that point cause they weren't using
me and i was little three four dying i
mean dying a slow death so
i say what did you bring me here to do
excuse me i said what did you bring me
here to do attacked the quarterback i
said i can't do it if i'm on the
sideline on a 3-4 i need four up front
and i'll give a damn what they play
behind they can play cover zero nine
whatever right 57 whatever we're going
to get the quarterback he said i'll fix
it
the monday we go and watch the tape
tuesday we off we come back
wednesday morning robbo's sitting at the
top of this
stage with the grease board up and his
hair is everywhere
he looked like he has a pound of dude
underneath his nose i mean he has a look
on his safe eagles i can't believe it
one of my players went to the effing
owner to change the defense burj is down
in front look back say is that you big
homie
i said yes sir
across 99 56 91 93 and we're gonna play
man-to-man behind it
i looked up i said what i learned is
that just bought me another half a
second let's go
we went into tennessee i had three sacks
stacked steve mcnair god bless his soul
for sad cause former robbo came to me in
the locker room after the game grabbed
me and looked at me and said that's all
money kevin was doing all these years
i said pretty much but let him tell me
to lose so third down i'd get it done
and now we had the number three defense
and two wins but hey you know that's
that's all in the world
yeah i had to go to alley
i didn't know that so if you wanted to
just go to jerry and dallas you've got
to go to jerry right cool who else calls
the shots
well he's supposed to be the coach right
i mean but not in cowboy
it's called joe mahal for a reason baby
warren sapp here on the rich eisen show
all right let me just get right to it
let's go right to the meat and potatoes
99 in your program number one in your
heart here in los angeles how good is
aaron donald the best thing going
besides i can't say that um since sliced
bread i mean
you know what i was watching him in the
game yes and they had put him in that
mike march when you remember man mike
marsh used to talk about the 99
championship game yeah well he said he
just threw everything in the kitchen
sink at me yes that's what they did in
the first half of this game
and for some reason the cincinnati
bengals in their quarterback decide to
wake this monster up
i mean you give him the sack because you
don't run out of bounds or you know he
pushes you
no problem
then they decide to smash him and
they hit him in the face rich and they
woke this monster up they went to
scheming with a little just a little
wrinkle in the defense to mug the center
and my god did he wake up and go through
that guard ran right through him and
just turned it up and then von miller
turned it up on the last drive right
i
was on the phone with a friend of mine
who used to be a hall of fame voter and
he was like listen shop joe burl is
driving it i said listen here son this
is a past rusher's dream right now i
just need one
i just need one rush right now and i'm a
world champion right there's no way joe
bro gets away not with that old line
and today
two three days after super we still
can't name those five guys
that's what i tell you you can't have
the offensive player your comeback
player whatever joe burrow was all these
beautiful things and have him under that
kind of pressure
you know in that kind of situation for
the world championship he didn't have a
chance to look at anybody and they're
showing me
uh jamar chase made uh
jaylen ramsey falls right the front and
the back end worked together
you got
we quote you all the time about that
front in the back and work together so
all right uh rewind a little bit so that
moment when burrow gets hit by donald
and i i mean he he hit him literally
out of mouth oh out of bounds come on
right now his foot he pushed him oh he
pushed him right he wasn't out of bounds
he was clearly in the field of power no
doubt and ready to be hit all
go get your quarterback go back to the
huddle
leave this monster alone
you just gave him a sack
so let him get his gift wrap sack go
back to the huddle and now find a way to
block him again and then drive the ball
do not push this man in the face and
wake him up
now you got all 11 round up mm-hmm
trust me i remember that i remember that
moment and then of course he comes up
with a sack to stop the drive after they
move the ceiling he runs right through
the guard
through him right and then that that
kept him to three after the pick after
the the the touchdown to start the
second half and that's
that kept it you know that kept it a one
score game and so and then obviously
donald calling game
at the end of the game oh so it's
interesting i i warned zap here in the
ritual show you talking about throwing
kitchen sinks and all that sort of stuff
at him
what do you make of a 30 year old saying
he's thinking of retiring even though he
hasn't said it
but word out there is that he's thinking
of retiring do you believe it do you
what do you think yes
i mean the money they're giving them i
mean why not
put it somewhere and invest in bitcoin
or whatever crypto and and go sit on the
beach and enjoy your children because
he's done enough
i mean look at the wrestlemania he's in
your he's in your oh no no he's above me
he's above me he's above you listen rich
i look i looked at this thing with the
seven straight all pros
i can't name a guard that he's going
against but you know he's still seven
straight all pros i mean he's still
rushing the hell out of that quarterback
i mean
he can get it that's why i'm saying you
know retiring i don't like his run game
play not at all cause you can't never
show me a game when somebody ran the
ball at me 40 times and beat me that's
it how did you move the ball
you're running at 40 times where did you
move it on these run plays because that
ain't going down not for four quarters
no i just i hate that part of this game
but everything else
impeccable so
you do i'm trying to get inside the the
mindset of somebody indeed
it'll be the sixth first ballot hall of
fame defensive tackle behind me
mean joe green merlin olsen bob lilly
and randy white
that's a six pack that you can not you
do not want to see on your sunday
afternoon
and then johnny randle backing us up i
mean it's unbelievable so
we got a collection
it's a collection of great men that
played the game at the defensive tackle
position and he's right there with all
of us well i'm just trying to get inside
the trenches where a 30 year old would
even be thinking yeah uh
look it up see how many defensive
linemen have
are 30 years plus and have 10 sacks it's
less than 15.
so you think it would be me reggie white
bruce smith
johnny randall a couple other guys like
that uh leslie uh leslie o'neill or
something like that some guys like that
but it's less than 10 or 15. it's only
10 or 15 of us so you believe the
conversation that that he might think be
thinking of retiring yeah i mean when
you get
bounced around and being boned
pinball around in that thing i mean
little hips in the moms you ache
you ache i mean i played 13 good years
in this thing and it hurt i got a new
hip and i'm ready to ride my bike and do
the fishing and scuba and everything
that i do but
this game will take a toll on you so
it's believable
he just looks like adonis and he makes
it look so easy you know so it's kind of
surprising that's what i'm saying it's
kind of surprising that he
because again
you know three times defensive player
world champion
pro bowls all pros
i don't know match by none except baby
bob lily and merlin olsen and me and joe
cause i think he had ten
yeah those guys are 10 12 for 13 14
years like that so
he's halfway there
for nfl honors uh
on uh on thursday night because this
kind of jarred my memory here a little
bit when you said that aaron donald's
above you is what you said okay so so
we had um
uh we had
um uh that thursday night uh for the
honors is your microphone on there i
don't know there is a time okay so
thursday night you know
freaking out over there
so so thursday night for the honors uh
when all the hall of famers that they
they asked to announce uh the incoming
class for for for honors
um because they had a specific
connection with them okay um the
everyone was wearing their gold jackets
but bruce decided to wear his burgundy
nfl 100 all-time team jacket
and i thought that was a flex
i thought that was a little bit of a
flex just to walk around say you know
there's there is there is a
step up they had a 100 sack club meeting
here in la2 did they really and i missed
it about three and a half
that was bruce
vonn right also donald right monsters
clyde simmons
uh d ware is in that and he didn't get
in
he didn't get in for his best kevin
heston's the all-time
most dangerous man that you would ever
think about kicking the ball to and he
didn't get here you know what i i am
blown away brother i had three canes
that was that have
pretty much
hall of fame resumes without it because
andre johnson you got to go get jerry
rice to top his numbers
that's jesus and clicks by
playmakers words
what am i missing here yeah reggie wayne
too was in the mix wayne got a nice
resume well he'll come in
can't even get a sniff i don't
understand that yeah well i looked at
them numbers you seen those numbers 85
touchdowns he's mvp
he's uh and and and he's sniff well he
played the game too in a different way
and when you're talking about a blocking
receiver yes sir
that's the first one change the rule for
him oh you can't even you can't even hit
nobody in the ear like that no more well
yeah they changed the rule because he
was the king of that i have a couple
rules myself rich
hey would you have rules against you in
the national
[Laughter]
came across and said something to me so
i you know
he's lucky mercedes cheryl sapp was in
that box leading over the top i looked
up there she was your daughter yeah yeah
she melts my
what i was thinking i was not going to
see the baby after the game
no i gotta go home to the baby baby sap
here on the rich eisen show okay so
what did you think of the hall of fame
class i am welcoming all brothers that
endured this process because it's so
funny to me now rich that
we see the the presentation that they do
now yep david baker's was lovely i
really like that i i don't mind the
connection with the guys leroy butler
with his socks off with his shoes off
and socks on and cold
but you can't fake it to us you already
know so
just so happen you show up at john lynch
house and he's got 40 of his closest
people there i mean he's just come on
let's let you know how i found out how'd
you find i have a video george chin
recorded me i didn't know he had it on
i'm standing on the table in the living
room at the hotel in new orleans right
yelling at the tv
that's when i found out just like
everybody else in the world found out i
found out right
i don't know it's kind of difficult now
with the with covert and there's no
hotels right so or they're they could i
guess have no you're not going to have a
show just like we had on tv then and you
watch it from your house like i did
[Music]
so uh
which is uh what did you think of
seymour's game back in the day
what'd you think of seymour's game back
in the day
i wish bill would have let him go
because they always told me that this
big six foot six monster from the you
know georgia bulldog national champions
first time since herschel walker so you
give him a little
[Music]
that he could rush and do the things
that he that were very special and i
always said that i would never constrain
someone that's that
generational of a player you gotta let
him go
gotta let him go 57 and half sacks don't
say richard seymour
[Music]
but that's what he has right so those
are the numbers though that's the
numbers
and bryant young
coming in the home oh man brian almost
90 sacks was in the middle of that san
francisco 40 minutes you were saying
that they had haley and dolman who were
in that canton room with you and b c b y
was the guy with the c on his chest and
they had uh stubblefield right beside
him that one defensive player of the
year right
right
so hey you know how san francisco is
they they mount up a bunch of talent
that come after you full of [ __ ] but you
know i i know a lot of uh very proud
hurricanes as you know you are one of
them irv is another one of them i can go
on and on and on it's kind of wild how
the one if you will snub
that gets everybody upset is hester
that's true
it's play this game
to identify the most dangerous guy on
the football field and boy when you was
kicking that ball every but no one went
to the bathroom no one went to the
concession stand you don't go nowhere to
either kick it out of bounds or kick it
through the end zone because once hester
got his hands on it
my goodness what a what a delight to
watch i i think maybe it's it's just
folks that's tony dungy tony dungey went
to the greatest showing of the super
bowl as we're just leaving i know what
he did he went in front of the special
team we're gonna kick it to him we're
gonna go down there we're gonna set the
tone touchdown coach
just like that coach this is the one who
told us the story about
dungey saying like i guess the the
lord's prayer that he he had read before
the game was the like the same one
from the movie hoosiers about david and
goliath
and that um that he took it the wrong
way as to mean
king
she said reggie white didn't have it
anymore we're gonna go to green bay and
grab reggie white
jason yes with jason odom i'm sorry od
but it was jason owen from the
university of florida we're going to go
to green bay and block reggie white with
jason owen
boy jason oldham reggie white had three
sacks and blocked a punch
we got home i can't even see you totally
on that buddy i said coach can you
please give the opposing defensive live
with the same attention that i get
please don't ever do that to me again my
bad ones
but that was his coaching
just to talk it up
it was a feeling with tony tony yeah
tony prayed on everything you know this
and if he had a feeling that this is
what the message was that's where he
went i just read the message man i just
could not believe just when he kicked it
to devin mester to start that game and
then that hester then actually came
through with what we
were expecting in the biggest moment and
we're like oh can this actually happen
for the bears tonight now we all know
that it did oh no no no reg grossman was
a quarterback
you just had to be re-emphasized
that's why i'm just saying maybe the
selectors do not view kick returner punt
returner
as on par with receiver running back or
your position anybody's position what
i'm opposing
then that's the only
reason for not giving that
first balance status i saw something
ross tucker tweeted if they don't put
you know tony burcelli and richard
seymour in the hall of fame i'm taking
my name off the list i don't know who
the hell let you vote in the first place
no no i think he was just i'm serious
i'm serious i mean what did i miss
i think what you missed is ross
i don't think he's got a vote i think he
was just being self-effacing that he's
going to take his name off the list of
of candidacy oh okay oh that's what he
was saying
and you have no shot at it and you
talking oh god
what
what do you think of what's going on
with kyla murray what is happening with
kyla murray what do you think these kids
really need to understand do not let
your timeline become your lifeline
gentlemen and ladies out there in the
world
live a life that social media don't
dictate what's really going on
sometimes when i put you on fishing i'm
sitting on my couch
and why in the hell would you as the
franchise quarterback
of a franchise unfollow them
and then what did he do acid wash that
was the acid wash scrub yeah he just he
scrubbed it all off and then sick and
then saying nothing saying nothing
but that is the saying
yeah he's already told us but what is he
saying is the point like i don't know
what he's saying and i went out
but why would you want out in kingsbury
is basically but and i heard you earlier
and you was like
you know his money and whatever there's
no question he can play yeah it is
because that playoff game you're on as
good as your last game and i want to
know what the hell you were doing in
that end zone when you flipped that ball
up on that pick six
i've never seen that
we've looked at a lot of football rich
i've seen dan orlowski run out the back
of that thing with the cop ready to
throw for safety i've never seen that in
the pocket flip run click get ready to
fall and and just gift rap six
and you down 14.
oh man i
son
i
i watched that game and i wanted that
didn't look like an nfl quarterback huh
that didn't look like it i'm
not one in the playoffs
this is the playoffs
this is the best of the best a run for a
championship and that's your performance
you put up and then you want to scrape
your instagram of the cardinals maybe
the cardinals need to wipe themselves
for you son
because evidently you ain't on the right
program you
you don't do that out in the open like
go ahead and have a conversation when i
when i had my first year with the bucks
and everything went crazy we went two
and seven at the end
and sam weiss was running god bless
himself was running a a three-ring
circus and he was wringling brothers in
the middle with the big hat i went
straight to rich mckay i said no way i
can't do this he says calm down big
though
let me go get you a coach and you come
back and see me after the new year and
we'll see where we're at
that's what you do you go in and have a
conversation with the powers-to-be well
maybe he did and it didn't go the way
that he wanted well then you suck it up
like a grown man and you wait for the
consequences because you already know
what's coming
why alert the world
yeah i don't i know why alert
that's exactly and that's why we talk
about it on shows like this and others
because why alert
but what you're also like but no no it's
your minion of followers to back you off
oh they need to do this they need what
does that mean millions of followers if
they have their contractual control on
you you need to force your way out i
mean that's the real deal with the
people behind you well so that's what
like so so let's dive into this a little
bit more sap like why why alert the
world i don't know we didn't live in
that social media world the less you
said the better your chances were this
turning out well for you because there's
less people that know it
that's when a conspiracy starts with two
or three people get together and come up
with a wild plan well alert you me my
agent or my agent me and the tampa bay
buccaneers to negotiate right i left i
told rosa house here's the code to the
house i'm leaving
[Music]
i'm leaving because if the bucks says
something about me that i take personal
it's gonna be a long time before i wash
that off my back so you leave you take
the i always tell people whenever i do
the step in the lab i take the emotion
out i'm just watching the game i'm just
watching the tape i'm just watching
technique this ain't personal that's
what it is with a contract negotiations
everybody saw the big year at the end
that's why they set up these rookie
contracts so now your representative and
you have to be on board with the team
and then if they don't want to give you
this then find a nice easy way for me to
exit put me somewhere where i have a
little bit of say in it and let's move
on right but don't do this foolishness
and now me and rich got to sit here and
speculate and hypothesize about you
scrubbing your instagram and all this
foolishness
not right
what what ended up i don't think i would
have followed the bucks when i was on
the team
so there's nothing to talk about i don't
follow him i worked there
so what ended up happening was on super
sunday chris mortenson tweeted out that
you will see that okay see he tweets out
the odd vibe between the cardinals and
kyler murray is indeed alarming murray
is described as self-centered immature
and finger-pointed per sources
murray is frustrated with franchise that
was embarrassed by playoff loss to rams
and thinks he's being framed as the
scapegoat
and then he asks where's it headed
despite the ackmart of the cardinals
expect things to calm down and murray is
their qb i mean he's under contract
unless he demands out right the select
veterans here's the one select veterans
hope to reach murray on how he handles
adversity better kingsbury also self
scouting where he could provide better
alternatives for the qb if you're a
veteran on the team i mean what do you
think that means that giving him
advice on how to handle things better
what do you think that means well
there's three things in the locker room
discuss your wife your children and
money
ain't got nothing to do with your
contract dollar you gotta handle it on
your own son you come in here do your
job i'm gonna do mine we're gonna pull
together and everyone together everyone
achieves more in a team situation what
if handling things better means in the
adversity of uh of a game what do you
what you know handling things hey
man it's time to step up this is a
professional league you know they get a
chat too
sometimes they're better than you
sometimes we we didn't execute
but like i said rich that last playoff
game it didn't look like an nfl
quarterback to me something was really
really off
so what could that have been i don't
know
i don't know maybe it was some
negotiation that they were talking about
they were going to settle up because
they did start off high
they started a lot and then probably
your agent is calling and like let's go
finish this thing before it gets too
crazy and now the number is way out of
you know astronomical so it's money you
think it's got to be the contract
because that's the security in which we
all want to go to work with right
and put yourself on the wall
how much do you love me where the money
at
warren sapp here on the rich eisen show
show friends
yeah what do you think what do you think
of brady having uh six days between
announcing retirement and saying never
say never it's not easy to let go rich
especially when you went for 53 what
53-16 led the league in passing i mean
there's nothing wrong with that tampa
bay team except the defense they can't
rush the passer from inside you know my
two tackles inside just they don't
believe in russian pass
we just we play run it's not earl
campbell in the backfield crazy they're
throwing the ball so but it's tough when
you're talking about someone with that
kind of excellence that kind of drive
that kind of focus right
hey phil sims used to say something to
me when i work with him on inside the
nfl he's like you just walked away
you're in good shape and everything i'm
like yo man it's time he's like they
would have to pry the helmet from my
cold dead fingers
i see he played in a different league
it's a little bit better money situation
so
that's why aaron donald could decide to
go home because it's just a different
situation but
for somebody like brady i mean he's
right there if todd bowles don't call it
all out blitz and his bucks don't don't
run it i mean come on my my linebacker
lavonte david is standing with his hands
on his hip that's the place going on
unbelievable man i mean just come on
your last pass is to mike evans over the
top of the number one cornerback in the
national football league
for six
and that's how you ah
what do you think the bucks are going to
do oh my goodness
you know who his backup was right yes
sir all righty we need to do
quarterbacks
fast
so
you know i i don't know did russell
wilson don't like tampa yeah we got some
good stuff down there we got an
amphitheater though
big shows though
no taxes am i tambourine yeah no taxes
no taxes yeah
he already know that he's smart enough
to know that
ain't that
sierra first started so that's it like
it's it's jason light taking a big swing
over the next four weeks why wouldn't he
right why wouldn't you i don't know you
you you think kyle trask you can start
something there so so does growth come
back without without brady no that's but
that's the whole thing i won't come back
without brady but if i'm if i'm jason
light and i hear tom brady have only
three business days or five days at his
home
saying never say never
i'm thinking all right the light's still
on a little bit didn't he have a
contract that he's leaving he's kind of
he still is on the team that's what i'm
saying i mean i think we should have no
i i know that and if i i heard that and
even though i i mean you know the final
man in the arena episode is all about
him walking away
and that gives you a mind an enter of
his mindset about what he's 44. no i
know that's the most amazing thing about
him warren is he's a 44 year old guy and
i'm surprised that he's stepping away
yeah
i know
it's crazy so that's what i'm saying if
i'm tampa i'm kind of playing it a half
measure in a way because listen i want
brady to come back but before you make
that decision to go all out now you call
you make the call
you make the call and what if he's what
if he says yeah i'm still i'm
go do you gotta go forward then you've
got to go forward what happens if brady
then decides around the middle of the
summer
you have the contract and i have two
premier quarterbacks
then you then you clearly but not if you
let's say you do make a big move and
somehow you do get some big veteran name
like you said russell wilson say you
know um
i don't know if this happens on this
green earth but aaron rodgers something
like that is what i'm saying and brady
says i want to come back then you trade
him and you get something back would you
have a problem if brady tells the bucks
if he i don't know go somewhere else and
i'll decide no no you keep rogers and
you trade brady that's what i'm saying
yes that's what i'm saying yes that's
that's what i would say yes correct so
you would have no way you go with the
forty five before you have a problem
with brady saying i don't know right now
and then decide summer i kind of do and
plays it that way because he maybe
wanted something i don't have a problem
with it because it's so hard to let go
rich it is i mean you just come on with
a career like that with numbers like
that and still performing like that
right i left because i couldn't rest the
pastor anymore i knew it was a payouting
pass brett favre did that little wiggler
came out i tried to rush this kid he had
me locked up
he threw it over the top the driver i
said i told the kid you won't let me go
now
the ball go the kid finally let me go i
looked up 85-yard touchdown yeah it's
time to go home i knew it was pass and i
still couldn't get the brightest rush i
want that's when i knew it was time to
go home brady's last play was over the
top to mike evans on the best corner
back in the game
over the world champ
yes yes correct the champ right yeah and
his last snap was a handoff to fournette
for a touchdown to tie the game down
27-3 ties the game 27 like i said
i know and it wasn't drew brees it
wasn't peyton manning with the arm
strength no it wasn't another yeah
in the air on a rope
i mean in the bucket
boom you know what do you think aaron's
just thinking did
what do you think he said please please
come back
just every day texting like hey
hey what's going on you know you know
she's covered daytime drinking has
really become a thing i think moose is
doubling it up right now
do you know who our backup was
bruce might be doing something other
than just drinking something
part of the thing the reason why i'm
bringing it up as well is this just a
concept that maybe at this advanced
stage of his life career he just doesn't
want to run it back with some of
somebody else somebody else um or he
already said he wants to call plays
maybe if bluff switch had gone so i so
i'm just wondering what you think his
mindset is going into this offseason do
you think he still wants to do it bruce
yes
you listen man i
didn't they say bruce right around on
the golf cart
yeah i think his problem is his achilles
might be that's what i'm saying why i
run the golf cart they're getting tough
call plays from the golf cart yeah at
practice i mean you don't use that i
mean because that that
you ever heard that that intercom thing
right oh the helmet yeah
oh my god i used to tell cause i don't
know how you go home at night after the
four quarters of that oh my goodness
that that is that is not an easy thing
to oh my goodness
warren sapp here on the rich eisen show
a few minutes left here what do you
think of uh stafford as a hall of famer
do you think he's a hall of famer i
think his numbers will
but as far as
the shake the handles of the game
i don't know no more it ain't for me to
decide no i know that richard
richard sherman's made it an issue
particularly you know obviously we've
been talking about
i'm not going to talk
i'm going to talk about he was talking
about on his podcast but the hof bar is
incredibly low now like a participation
trophy no all decade team no all pro no
mvp one pro bowl not even mvp of the
super bowl never considered the best and
he's talking about stafford never
considered the best in any year he
played at least matt ryan has an mvp
is what richard sherman says okay uh in
response to my
is richard sherman colleagues to
critique the class that just went in
i don't know
then how has he already got to matthew
stafford let's call him champ
well let's be on to the next season i
think what he's responding to i guess is
the whole setup is that everybody in the
media has been talking about you know as
we always do waiting for a super bowl
and hyping it up that if stafford had
won
and he just did
that the numbers that he has 50 000
passing
yards got silly fighters it had no
defense to back up everything that him
and megatron was doing that and i was
saying some games in detroit that boy
did not play bad yeah he lit up the
scoreboard and had nothing to back it up
no run game either oh no yeah they had a
running back they went on 16.
they ran kevin smith's
death this is what i'm saying is that
the reason why he didn't have these
actors because he didn't have aaron
donald and von miller and some other
people on the other side yeah i would
and i would his numbers
hey we gonna say that that if he had
because we all thought devin hansen was
a first ballot right
i thought so too so
that's what so do you think matthew
stafford is a hall of famer warren sapp
at no point in me watching matthew
stafford play and he's still playing
have i looked at him and said there's a
hall of famer
i can say that if he gets his gold
jacket out welcome him in have a drink
with him tell him welcome to the club of
course but now i've never looked at
matthew stafford at any point in his
life in a playing career and said
that is a hall of famer could that be
because he's playing in detroit you know
whatever when he was playing with the
rams this year going for whatever y'all
see through for throwing two
interceptions and three touchdowns the
other night and having nothing but
cooper cup to go to and i don't know how
to heal the cincinnati bengals then
double him and make him throw the number
18. i
collins weren't for having trouble with
his name so i was like yeah
[Music]
bingles
well i don't know man again like he's
got numbers staffordshire what is tony
romo at 40 000 is he a hall of famer no
okay no he's not but stafford now has a
ring
i mean that doesn't matter and he did
have that drive in this with six minutes
to go and he had a terrific postseason
and i understand that people were like
well then put flacco in but it's a
totally different ball no it's a
different ball
joe flacco doesn't have 50 000 passing
yards and and by what by the time it's
all said and done stafford could have a
second ring and he could but obviously
even if he doesn't he's gonna have he's
gonna have thousands upon thousands of
more passing yards and and you can't
make the pro bowl in detroit though
that's exactly right um honestly put
whatever
said
i mean all of those things that that
that that sherman said he could not
achieve in detroit and he spent 12 years
there i mean are you going to be an
all-pro quarterback in detroit when when
you know in the nfc farms doing it too
at the same time and you know this is
like you know and well
no well farvard already left mike i mean
you know
it was stacked well no favre was still
around actually i mean
or or i don't know and everyone else in
the nfc was doing what they were doing
just off the top my head i'm trying to
name who are they all pro nfc
quarterbacks were at the time but
at any rate and then um give me the year
and then i can help you with it but
other than that well i mean i guess he
he comes in
2009 yeah old man right when i retired
right
so far was still around i mean he was
doing it
right
12 right exactly all right i know paul
was always
don't
around
i'm capable no no listen matthew
stafford when it's all said and done
puts another one on
maybe maybe one's an mvp ain't no talent
i mean because sean mcvay is going to
throw this ball
unless he's going to be in the booth
john mcveigh might leave to go to be an
announcer
oh you know what i'm done with this
i i used to say after we won the
championship in tampa i showed back up
in tampa after we won the super bowl
everybody had a damn ready show
everybody had a billboard everybody had
this everybody had that i'm like we're
gonna get our ass kicked ain't nobody
working out in the whole season so
you're telling me aaron donald's gonna
retire sean mcveigh is going to the to
the booth
maybe yeah are you kidding me i'm not
i'm not they do write some crazy scripts
in l.a
do you know
well they write big checks and i think
that's yeah do you know who's got a job
open in a booth for next year nbc
jeff bezos yeah it's got a job open
yeah jeff bezos
amazon is host is airing thursday night
football starting this fall
yeah man
jeff bezos is going to write checks
well i can do my thing and show you
who's going right
if i'm on thursday
i don't think he's the one who's making
the phone calls but just say you
represent jeff bezos that's enough for
me okay
uh everything's good in your hood what
are you doing little girl came home with
a master's degree
there's a master's degree with sap
underneath that is a beautiful thing
rich so she's one degree just shy of
being dr sapp i don't think she's going
for that
degree the baby don't come on with it
now i need to get a job richard you know
somebody
okay
the baby job not me
okay all right and then the boys like
fau and everybody's good and healthy
mom's good and healthy kicking rump so i
can't complain oh you already know baby
thank you thank you for coming in warren
hey just who's in the kids i say hello i
appreciate that she's probably out there
right now saying hello to you so thanks
for calling in brother i mean coming in
come on great to see you always
if he texts me during uh game day
morning
listen
to kevin garnett
it's so great you're like you're like
monster week yeah okay hold on man give
give this man a pen one of the photos
it's like monster week you must have you
must have had a lot of great guests and
i'm like are you in town like you just
let me know you're in town you know
you're in town heads up he kills me and
i booked him in the middle of hour three
of game day morning
i forgot to i forgot to send it on the
list to say send him an email to come
here all right warren sapp at
warren sapp on twitter and on instagram
right here on the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here